el vehículo en el que viajaba daria
dukina explotó en la noche del sábado a
40 km de moscú
la hija del ideólogo ultra nacionalista
ruso alexander du king un cercano aliado
de vladimir putin murió en el lugar las
autoridades rusas ya abrieron una
investigación por homicidio
en este momento los investigadores y
especialistas forenses del comité de
investigación de rusia así como expertos
en bombas trabajan en la escena del
crimen mientras que alexander iba a
viajar en ese vehículo y a última hora
cambió de planes por lo que la familia
considera que él era el blanco del
supuesto ataque doguín seguidor del
eurasia mismo corriente política que
concibe a rusia como el centro de una
civilización expresó abiertamente su
apoyo a reunificar todos los territorios
de habla rusa en el contexto de la
invasión de rusia ucrania
el kremlin responsabiliza a kiev si se
confirma el rastro ucraniano entonces
debemos hablar de la política de
terrorismo de estado llevado a cabo por
el régimen de kiev
y el gobierno de volodymyr selenski
desmintió estar detrás del ataque y por
el contrario advirtió que teme una
ofensiva por parte del ejército ruso el
24 de agosto cuando además de cumplirse
seis meses desde la invasión se
conmemora el día de la bandera ucraniano
alexander dogging está sancionado desde
2015 por eeuu por amenazar la paz
seguridad y soberanía territorial de
ucrania tras la anexión de la península
de crimea mientras que su hija
periodista y politóloga de 29 años
estaba sancionada por tener un medio de
desinformación